savez-vous s'ils ont des armes à feu dans les
maisons ont des armes, je veux dire qu'il aime
le cœur, c'est un gars plutôt cool, vous
savez, je peux vous dire que ça a été vraiment
difficile, je veux dire que sa femme est mieux inquiète
ce matin-là Rick, je me laisse avoir des
problèmes avec  m.  le lieutenant vert semble
que lui et sa femme ont bien regardé
les choses, je veux dire, vous savez, l'agent, regardez
hier soir, j'ai entendu des plans comme si nous n'étions pas des
conseillers matrimoniaux
J'ai eu deux autres expulsions
aujourd'hui,
je vais contacter le [ __ ] d'Orlando pour obtenir une
sauvegarde, vérifiez que sa
famille est là avec lui, il y a
vraiment de l'espoir, je veux dire qu'elle est venue au-dessus de
cette eau et elle pleurait, ça va
rappeler
tout droit  allez vérifier ouais
merci pour le play-by-play dépêchez-vous ma
femme et mes enfants sont dans cette maison
je suppose que kill mark [ __ ] de [ __ ] de [ __ ] de [ __ ] de [ __ ] de [ __ ] de
[ __ ] je ne vais PAS partir d'ici [ __ ]
j'adore
mettez ça mettez le mettez ça
n'arrivera pas asseyez-vous monsieur pourquoi n'envoyez-vous pas
votre femme avec vos enfants
arme